feathery looks are back in fashion one
thing that makes feathers stand out as a
fashion device is that they change the
profile of the individual Charles Darwin
even commented in one of his writings
when he said the head is the chief seat
of adornment true in people and also
true in Birds where you see feathers in
a Crest that is visible from a long way
off telling one bird what species of
bird it's looking at biologist and
author Torah Hansen explores the
unexpected origins of feathers in
fashion and how our quest for plumes
brought some species to the brink of
Extinction
we find plumage attractive in the same
way that birds find it attractive we
have co-opted them for many of the same
purposes for which they evolved in
nature
the history of feathers in human
Fashions runs deep indigenous cultures
around the world co-opted feathers from
local birds often as displays of social
status elaborate feather capes were made
in the Hawaiian Islands on certain South
Pacific Islands people use them as a
currency the Aztecs made feathered
costumes detailed paintings the nazkas
in Peru the Egyptians had strong
Traditions about the importance of
feathers in their culture so feathers
Run Deep In cultures in mayo fashion
feather work for a long time was
associated with the military and prowess
on the battlefield the very phrase a
feather in his cap comes to us from a
tradition where feathers were added to
the Helms of Warriors who performed well
during battles throughout time rare and
expensive plumes were used by the
wealthy to convey status but it wasn't
really until the 19th century that
feather work in fashion expanded and
became focused on which women's looks
specifically feathered hats ostrich
feathers in particular had great value
as well at that time so much so that in
South Africa there were ostrich ranches
where they had up to a million birds
under domestication and you could
harvest the feathers from domesticated
ostrich sustainably by clipping the
feather off at the base and the birds
would simply grow a new set of plumes in
the next season so ostrich feathers had
so much value at that time that it is a
point of fact that when the Titanic sank
in 1912 the most valuable cargo on the
ship was not some fancy diamond as you
might see in the movies but it was
feathers 40 cases of prime ostrich
plumes on their way from the feather
merchants of London to the hatmakers of
New York City and valued in today's
dollars at nearly two and a half million
dollars at the peak of the Gilded Age
Bird hat craze famed ornithologist Frank
Chapman was astounded at the variety of
species he observed on the streets in
1886 he walked through the financial
district and he quickly managed to
tabulate 40 different species of birds
that he might have seen in Central Park
but they were all adorning the hats of
the women walking down the street this
of course was having a terrible impact
on wild bird populations really around
the world one of the casualties was the
Carolina Parakeet which went extinct in
the wild in 1904 a victim of hunting and
deforestation another species being
ravaged was the snowy egret it had
wonderful plumes that held their shape
in all sorts of great ways and so it led
to these great hunting efforts that were
wiping out Egret colonies it doesn't
take long for that sort of hunting
practice to bring the populations
crashing down the desire for beautiful
hats and other fashion items was driving
in some cases close to the extinction of
some of what had once been common birds
this is where we see the beginnings of
the Audubon Society through groups of
women organizing to push back against
this fashion craze and it led to this
idea that people should give up
something that may have value
economically to preserve things in
nature it was a radical idea at the time
but it led to the passing in North
America of bills and laws that are still
on the books protecting birds today
eventually during World War One
Feathered hats began to fall out of
favor with more women entering the
workplace and the rise of automobiles
places where fancy plumed hats were
inconvenient
foreign
s out there are very few things in
nature that have evolved for as many
purposes as feathers yes they can be
beautiful and use for allurement in the
birds but they have also evolved to be
waterproof to protect the birds from the
elements there are feathers that are the
best insulation we know of wonderfully
fluffy trapping all that Heat against
the body of the bird and then of course
there are flight feathers that are an
airfoil shape giving them Wonder
maneuverability in flight and are now
very visible in the fossil evidence
within a particular lineage of dinosaurs
the theropods which include such famous
meat eaters as Tyrannosaurus Rex and the
Velociraptors and they had plumes that
resemble what we see today in Birds
display was an early use of feathers way
back in the dinosaurs there are fossils
so well preserved that they contain
structures that allow paleontologists to
interpret the color of the feathers is
little organelle is called melanosomes
are associated with color we know that
dinosaur feathers were colored we know
that they must have been used for
display so this history of plumage that
is used for attracting mates used for
various displays in the bird kingdom has
a very very long history
because feathers are used in mating
rituals to attract a mate there's great
evolutionary pressure on their shape and
on their color and on their
effectiveness at that task and that
means that there is a huge range of
feather colors and shapes in nature
different ways that birds have evolved
their plumage for that sense of
allurement the birds of paradise have
evolved not only elaborate plumage but
incredible dances to go along with them
where they have medallions of colored
feathers and they have elaborate Wing
feathers where they thrust them up
behind them so you almost lose the shape
of the bird in this creative display of
feather work and it's typically the
males of the species that do this sort
of display and so you end up in these
situations of what biologists call
runaway selection where because the
females have a preference
for a particular look in the males
there's increased pressure for evolution
to make that look even more and more
extreme and that leads us to display
feathers of a peacock for example
totally outrageous and with no function
in nature other than to look good for
females we all know ostriches are
flightless they gave up the ability to
fly and followed a different
evolutionary strategy gaining large size
fast running capabilities to live on the
savannas of Africa so where you see a
typical flight feather that has a closed
vein and an offset rakis to give it an
aerodynamic airfoil shape the ostriches
have done away with that completely the
flight feather of an ostrich looks like
this the veins are not closed whatsoever
they have lost all those things and
evolved specifically for purposes of
display some biologists feel that the
elaborate feather work is what we call
an honest display that it must be
connected to some advantage that you
might get from mating with that
particular male other biologists feel
that this sort of runaway selection can
just be Beauty for beauty's sake it
doesn't actually connect to anything
about their vigor It's Not Unusual to
see ostriches featured heavily in
fashion because they have these
wonderful large lustrous feathers that
aren't used for display on the birds
they are decorating her arms in a sense
which is extremely appropriate because
these are flight feathers from probably
a male ostrich to have that much luster
and display
when we go to a function like the Met
Gala it's almost like going bird
watching in a way the idea of allurement
to look beautiful to attract attention
isn't it a happy coincidence we find
feathers beautiful in the same ways that
birds do they use them to display to one
another we can borrow them and use them
to display amongst ourselves meaning
that we have a lot more in common with
Our Feathered Friends than we might have
ever thought